hallo willkommen
ich bin emma ich bin emma ich komme aus
münchen aber ich bin vor einem jahr
hierher gezogen und lebe jetzt in bern
in der schweiz
ich komme aus münchen aber ich bin vor
einem jahr hierher gezogen und lebe
jetzt in bern in der schweiz
ich lebe nicht allein denn ich habe
einen hund und eine katze
ich möchte dir gern mein haus zeigen
heute lernen wir wörter zum thema haus
heute lernen wir wörter zum thema house
los geht's los geht's
willkommen das ist mein wohnzimmer
das ist das sofa
sofa ist bequem und mir gefällt die
farbe
das sofa ist bequem und mir gefällt die
ich sitze oft auf dem sofa und sehe fern
das sofa
das ist der fernseher
ist groß und modern
ich kann meine lieblings
fernsehsendungen oder lieblingsfilme
sehen
ich kann meine lieblings
fernsehsendungen oder lieblingsfilme
sehen
der fernseher
das ist der sessel
hier sitze ich und leser mein
lieblingsbuch
dieser sessel ist alt aber er gefällt
mir sehr gut
der sessel
dieser kleine kaffeetisch wurde mir von
meiner mutter geschenkt
mir gefällt die farbe
wenn ich morgens kaffee trinke erinnere
ich mich an meine mutter
der kaffeetisch
auf dem tisch stehen zwei porzellan
stücke und eine vase
das porzellan und die vase habe ich zur
dekoration dieses tisches gekauft
das porzellan
die vase
den teppich unter dem tisch habe ich aus
afrika mitgebracht
ich war für sechs monate in afrika in
einem austauschsemester ich war für
sechs monate in afrika in einem
austauschsemester
ich bin nämlich tierärztin ich bin
nämlich tierärztin der teppich
ich habe zwei haustiere einen hund und
eine katze der hund heißt rudolf und die
katze heißt clementina sie schlafen hier
ich habe zwei haustiere einen hund und
eine katze der hund heißt rudolf und die
katze heißt clementina sie schlafen hier
das ist ihr bett hier essen und trinken
sie wasser
das ist der kamin das ist der kamin
ich zünde den kamin an wenn es sehr kalt
ist
ist ich trinke gern heiße schokolade mit
marshmallows ich trinke gerne heiße
schokolade mit marshmallows der kamin
ist mein esszimmer
dieser tisch ist groß und aus holz
wir essen hier wenn freunde zu besuch
kommen
normalerweise benutze ich ihn nicht wenn
ich allein zu hause bin
normalerweise benutze ich ihm nicht wenn
der tisch
ich habe diese stühle vor kurzem gekauft
ich habe sie in einem second
hand laden gekauft ich habe sie in einem
secondhand laden gekauft der stuhl
auf dem flohmarkt habe ich diese schöne
lampe gekauft
obwohl sie sehr wertvoll ist konnte ich
sie günstig kaufen obwohl sie sehr
wertvoll ist konnte ich sie günstig
kaufen
kürzlich ging eine glühbirne aus
die lampe
dieses gemälde war ein
eines freundes
dieses gemälde war ein geschenk eines
freundes
ich mag abstrakte gemälde
ich mag es wenn das bild viele farben
hat
das gemälde
das bild
jetzt zeige ich euch meine küche
das ist meine küche
ich mag sie weil sie groß und hell ist
am besten gefällt mir dass es viel platz
zum kochen mit freunden gibt
die küche
das ist der geschirrspüler
der geschirrspüler
ich muss den geschirrspüler reparieren
weil er undicht ist
dieses haus ist nicht neu und manchmal
geht etwas kaputt
der geschirrspüler
das ist der herr
das ist der herd
mein herz ist mein bester freund
dort bereite ich die köstlichsten
gerichte zu
mein herz ist mein bester freund denn
dort bereite ich die köstlichsten
gerichte zu
meine familie und freunde besuchen mich
oft weil sie mein essen lieben
der herd
das ist der ofen
das ist der ruf
ich backe kuchen im ofen
der ofen
hier ist der kühlschrank
ich bewahre mein essen mein obst und
meine getränke im kühlschrank auf
der kühlschrank
die wanduhr die du dort hängen siehst
ist eine reliquie
ist eine reliquie diese wanduhr hat mir
mein großvater geschenkt
diese wanduhr hat mir mein großvater
geschenkt
er sagte hemmer lernen die zeit zu
schätzen
sie ist etwas das verschwindet und nicht
wiederkommt
er sagte immer lernen die zeit zu
schätzen
sie ist etwas das verschwindet und nicht
wiederkommt
die wanduhr
dass meine freunde ist die mikrowelle
ich benutze sie nicht oft aber manchmal
wärme ich mein abendessen darin auf
die mikrowelle
hier sind die küchenschränke
in ihnen bewahre ich die gläser die
täler und das besteck auf
ich verwende viele große teller
dieses messer ist stumpf ich muss es
schärfen
ich esse lieber mit der gabel als mit
dem löffel
ich benutze den löffel für die suppe
gläser die ich habe sind aus glas
die gläser die ich habe sind aus glas
die küchenschränke
das glas
die teller
das besteck
das messer
die gabel
der mixer
die bratpfanne
in der bratpfanne koche ich das fleisch
nachmittags trinke ich gerne eine tasse
kaffee
die kaffeetasse
schließlich der toaster
mein toaster ist klein aber ich benutze
ihn jeden tag beim frühstück
ein toaster ist klein aber ich benutze
der toaster
das ist der raum in dem ich den
mülleimer aufbewahre
ist der raum in dem ich den mülleimer
aufbewahre
ich bringe den müll dreimal pro woche
raus ich bringe den müll dreimal pro
woche raus der mülleimer
maschine
auch hier ist die waschmaschine
jetzt erinnere ich mich dass ich für
morgen wäsche waschen muss
die waschmaschine
hier bewahre ich auch die utensilien für
die reinigung des hauses auf
nun wir fahren jetzt mit dem bart fort
das ist die toilette
hier ist das waschbecken oder lavabo
das waschbecken wurde vor
umgestaltet das waschbecken wurde vor
kurzem umgestaltet
das waschbecken
das lavabo
über dem waschbecken habe ich einen
spiegel
der spiegel
das ist die toilette
eine saubere toilette ist für die
gesundheit sehr wichtig
die toilette
das ist meine dusche
diese dusche gefällt mir weil sie groß
ist
die dusche
mein favorit hier drin ist meine
badewanne
ich liebe es zur entspannung ein
schaumbad in der badewanne zu nehmen
wenn ich von der arbeit nach hause komme
dusche ich mich im winter warm und im
sommer kalt
wenn ich von der arbeit nach hause komme
dusche ich mich im winter warm und im
sommer kalt
das gefällt mir hier
es gefällt mir hier
cham
com
ich zeige dir mein zimmer
hier ist mein bett
das bett ist so bequem dass ich jeden
morgen mit mühe aufstehen muss
das bett
meine kissen sind für mich unverzichtbar
meine kisten sind für mich unverzichtbar
sie sind federleicht
sie helfen mir nachts ruhig schlafen zu
können
das kissen
die decken waren ein geschenk von meinem
besten freund
sie sind besonders weil er sie mir beim
einzug geschenkt hat
sie sind besonders weil sie mir beim
die decken
das ist mein nachttisch
das ist mein nachtisch
hier bewahre ich meine persönlichsten
dinge auf
der nachtisch
fahren wir also mit der tour fort
mein kleiderschrank ist ein traum
ich benutze meinen kleiderschrank um
meine kleider und schuhe aufzubewahren
ich glaube ich verbringe viel zeit damit
zu überlegen was ich in meinen schrank
legen kann
ich glaube ich verbringe viel zeit damit
zu überlegen was ich in meinen schrank
legen kann
der schrank
die vorhänge die du hier siehst waren
schon da als ich in dieses haus einzog
ich mag die vorhänge nicht besonders
also wird mir meine tante neue vorhänge
machen
ich mag die vorhänge nicht besonders
also wird mir meine tante neue vorhänge
machen
die vorhänge
fenster ist groß
mein fenster ist groß
dieses fenster bietet einen blick auf
die stadt
das fenster
das ist das gästezimmer
hier schlafen meine freunde oder familie
wenn sie zu besuch kommen
dieser raum ist meinem sehr ähnlich
das gästezimmer
nun jetzt möchte ich dir vokabeln
außerhalb des hauses beibringen
lass uns rausgehen
okay wir sind draußen lasst uns anfangen
das ist mein garten das ist mein garten
im garten gibt es rosen
ich genieße sie jeden zweiten tag im
garten gibt es rosen
ich genieße sie jeden zweiten tag der
garten
ich habe auch ein schwimmbad dass ich im
sommer sehr genieße ich habe auch ein
schwimmbad dass ich im sommer sehr
genieße das schwimmbad
das ist mein grill
das ist mein grill wir benutzen ihn im
sommer die ganze zeit wir benutzen ihn
im sommer die ganze zeit der grill
hier ist die garage
hier ist die garage in der garage stehen
zwei autos aber mir gehört nur eins in
der garage stehen zwei autos aber mir
gehört nur eins ich habe auch ein
schönes wähle ich habe auch ein schönes
velo die garage
von dort oben kann man das dach sehen
das dach des hauses ist ein bisschen alt
ich muss es renovieren das dach des
hauses ist ein bisschen alt ich muss es
renovieren das dach
im allgemeinen mag ich mein haus sehr
im allgemeinen mag ich mein haus sehr es
ist mein traumhaus
es ist mein traumhaus nun ich hoffe dass
dir diese führung durch mein haus
gefallen hat und du einige neue vokabeln
gelernt hast nun ich hoffe dass dir
diese führung durch mein haus gefallen
hat und du einige neue vokabeln gelernt
hast
bis später bis später